thank you you look amazing too you know
i'm getting a little bit emotional
because i haven't been on a red carpet
in two years and i was talking amanda
about coming to see you and how are you
very well you're very well i feel the
same way yeah i feel the same way like i
just kept saying now you sure there's no
social distance we don't have to have
masks everywhere because you don't know
you know am i allowed to sign i'm not so
finding all of these moments and kind of
it is it is emotional now 2015 we're on
the vienna red carpet and i said you
need to pull off top gun too and you
said to me that's gonna be tricky it's
always tricky did i ultimately convince
you
it was the moment and i figured i went
home and i was like i'm gonna do it but
but i'm telling you you when you said
that and every people say it and i i do
go home and i think about how could i do
it how would we do it and
i think there's
there's an element of having produced
the mission movies that gave me a level
of confidence but also
i just kind of wrote down
all the things that
these are the things that would at least
put us in a position to be able to make
it everyone had to be committed 100
everyone had to here's the things that
had to be practical action we had to
really evaluate the tone
and see i didn't want to just do a cover
of the first one you know what i mean by
that i just didn't want to be imitative
and
it means so much to people the audience
and i
did it i don't know
it
wasn't just me it was like everyone
involved did it everybody
you know everyone they they were
relentless throughout and and
you know mchugh joe jerry the entire
cast and supported the studios it was
everyone involved now the engineer in me
was
blown away with some of these scenes you
got to explain to me that force that
g-force that's on your body your mind
your brain
like i lost it i lost it i was like okay
force equals mass yes
and also think about those cameras
inside that aircraft the position of
those aircraft the engineering to be
able to get those shots
that is what i wanted the audience to
feel and have it be
have them
be in there and have that kind of
experience with these characters it was
intense you know i mean i fly airplanes
i and i also had to prepare those actors
for it how do i prepare them for it so
there's a lot
i thought about it for many years how to
do it i loved it thank you so much i
really appreciate it so good seeing you
too are you gonna come back to toronto
yeah i'd like to one day
you